now who are you um i can't actually
remember the name of my character but
it was a while ago
do you dance a lot though yes thank you
for saving me i did
in that um
well uh nick frost is the lead guy and
uh he uh as a child i'm his sister
that's it i'm his sister
um
and as children uh he was salsa champion
endless cups and awards and things and
we used to go off and do competitions
and i was his dance partner and then
something happened and his life changed
and salsa wasn't for him after that
moment
and then cut to uh nick frost's present
day
or whatever his character is called and
um
he's called bruce
[Applause]
you know this feeling you filmed
something
nelson mandela
i play this bloke uh
okay so you play he he's a dancer so
he's uh and um yeah so for the film so
he falls enough um with rasheeda jones
um that's princess daughter right yes
yes she's beautiful she's she is
beautiful
and um
uh he discovers that am i giving away
the plot yes tell everything i think
maybe you've told us enough now
i'm going to shut you down he dances
again yes and uh but so do you think so
do you yeah and i know we know you're
not into big you're not a big
preparation but you must have had some
dancers i was forced to um because i had
to dance on screen so i had to practice
do you look good though well there is as
you know they have people who actually
can dance
yeah who uh because i can only spin
three times before i vomit
so we do we have a picture of you in
rehearsals where it doesn't look like
it's going that well
that's the best thing i've ever seen
i also love that you're wearing like a
full sweatsuit and heels
let's shoot albertons as well wow no i
think that's a glow of a heater or
something
but did you get good did you get good
well um yeah
or i don't know what the choreographer
would probably
be laughing um i got much better show
some moves go on one move
[Applause]
would have compromised you can i just
say all of you you owe me
we'll watch a clip we'll watch a clip
where you can't i'm so excited that was
very convincing
[Music]